SEP is so important because it opens your eyes and
opens your perspective to issues and challenges
and opportunities that your company may have
never encountered I've always leveraged my team
but really understanding the power of these
outside networks that you develop was was a very
big eye-opener for me it is about six to seven
weeks that you take out of your out of your life
for a whole range of education self-reflection
building relationships that last a lifetime
that then enable you to come out and change
your life in the ways that you would like to
change it you're taking away things that are
going to be with you for the rest of your life
it's going to change your trajectory on how you
lead teams how you think about problems how you
how you manage through different situations it's
with you forever as executives your time is such
a precious resource anything that you can do that
is going to save you time and save you time month
over month year over year is invaluable
so to me that's the real ROI of SEP